speaking of outrage let's let's bring a
person around and let's uh hear his
argument because apparently he was
talking to moff on stera before yeah
yeah you're coming in loud and clear
buddy what's up well yeah I'm I don't
think I'm outraged but um okay
um I I know you said that I misquote you
so I don't want to
um misquote you rich I want to make sure
that I got you correct
before you know I say anything because I
was talking with Mom and we were kind of
going back and forth a while back about
some of the things you said I agree with
some of the things in the in the
unplugged Alpha but a lot of things I
find like I said very defeatist so um I
guess you can let me know what you
actually believe I guess in that aspect
all right so so what items do you find
to feed us and what is your solution so
so the I the idea and I like that you
asked me my solution but the idea is
that
um
oh she's not yours she's just your turn
or girls don't wait or at the fin they
what they wait at the finish line for
men and or she always has someone in the
back burner there's always somebody okay
so still is one at a time yeah
she's not yours it's just your turn yeah
so what's your solution to that
so my solution is to kind of get out of
that mindset where if she's yours she's
yours and make sure she's yours I don't
see any reason why to kind of whine
about it and be like well she's just my
turn I'm not sure if she's gonna you
know stay with me and more just be like
no no this is nice let me just stop
there for a second I'll let moff and you
know Jaren chime in as well after I get
my oh hold on oh my bad it's my talking
points let me just said it first
um so
um you're talking about whining about it
and I'm curious to hear you explain when
you've heard me whine about anything
because I'm the furthest thing from a
whiner there's people out there on
YouTube that whine about [ __ ] all the
time
well yeah and not not you generally but
there was actually a guy I saw you talk
to and he was claiming to be an alpha or
whatever he was from Florida and he was
saying how his wife was a certain way I
don't know if you remember that
conversation but
um that kind I feel like obviously
you're not gonna whine about it and I
don't expect you to but I feel like
those who take that mindset kind of
whine about it if that makes sense so
I'm not saying you're whining about it
but it's okay me it has a spirit of kind
of whining behind it yeah so look man
like there's there's a demographic of
men out there that are defeatists that
basically
um like the whole thing with uh Tom
Brady and his divorce recently that was
just announced this week like you know
how many DMs I got from guys that were
like hey check out this article look uh
you know if Tom can't make her happy
then what chance do I have or some [ __ ]
like that right those are those are the
losers those are the the fetus I'm not
saying to
uh whine about anything and I certainly
don't myself I mean I've never
encouraged anybody to be a victim in
fact I explicitly State many times in my
book don't be a victim take ownership be
accountable and do the damn work but
it's just accepting the reality of the
world it's like saying you know well the
sun's hot
okay well what are you gonna do you're
gonna find some shade you're gonna throw
in some sunscreen you're going to wear a
long sleeve shirt you're going to put a
hat on
um I'm not going to whine about I'm just
going to say you know the sun's hot hot
and a reality of relationships in
um you know the human world is that
they're not
long-term pair bonded you know till
death do us part like they're not
particularly monogamous which is why I
say generally speaking if you're going
to invite a woman in your life just
understand that she's probably not yours
till death do us part it's probably just
going to be your turn right I'm not
saying it's that case 100 of the time
are there men and women that
um have gotten married committed to each
other for a lifetime and uh you know
died together and bend each other's only
one
yeah does it happen today still
very rarely anymore you know
um so that's just a reality of the world
I mean it's it's An Inconvenient Truth I
certainly don't think it's anything to
whine about I think it's just something
to accept that humans aren't very good
at monogamy and don't stick around with
each other for a very long time I mean
divorce rates are 50 they're 70 the
second time round
um just about any woman that you meet
like how old are you right now
33. yeah so just about any woman that
you meet right now is she a virgin when
you meet her probably not right so those
are the points that I'm making
yeah and I see that point my thing is
when it comes to holding on to your
woman I think you need to kind of not
have that mindset running through your
mind because you may think about hey
that's just the way the world is and
that's how you kind of have no that's
plugged in thinking like that's my point
like what I'm saying basically is if you
think that you can go to uh you know
basically go down to your knee propose a
woman give her a twenty thousand dollar
piece of dinosaur [ __ ] that's compressed
uh and you know set up a big party
invite all these people do the
invitations the you know plan out the
tables and the meals and everybody comes
over and you take your vows till death
do us part and sickness and like if you
actually think that that is a commitment
and it's long-term minutes forever then
why is the divorce rate 50 and why is it
that after eight years that uh couples
only report being in a state of love
only 13 of the time right like it's not
it's not a long term like even I to you
know to this day in a relationship in an
LTR I know that it could end right like
that's how I approach it
yeah for me I like to heck with it like
for me I have like 20K ring you're right
for me I what I did like obviously my my
proposal holding was like what a
thousand dollars right uh wedding bands
were about 500 so it's been about two
thousand dollars for the whole thing
it's been nothing much on the wedding
just poor house wedding stuff like that
and we weren't worried about and I know
what you mean those big giant um venues
and all that to me that's insane right
okay to me it was just like your focus
on the wrong Point man but that's not
what we're talking about see see I'm not
done I'm kind of building up to the
point so I see I I understand if you
don't let me finish you might not get
that but we're building up to it so my
thing is this put all your focus on
keeping your woman and all in in those
things not necessarily
um trying to whine and dine her now that
we go out to expensive places to eat uh
probably we would call them expensive or
from New York so it's probably not as
expensive as where I am now in Ohio but
we yeah we went out and did those things
but we put in the work of building the
relationship together so not just kind
of like this is just a girl that I'm
dating or that I'm kicking with this is
somebody that I'm planning on being
married I'm vetting her and we're going
to be uh married for long term I'm not
going to expect her to go out and run
out on me because are you are you
married right now are you just engaged
right now yeah sorry that's not yeah I'm
married right now that's not the woman
that I'm going to uh dedicate my life to
I'm going to make sure okay so you're
not married but you're talking as if you
were no I am married oh you are mayor
okay so how long have you been married
we married about 10 years or nine years
together 10 married not okay and was
your girlfriend a virgin when you met
her but my no your wife but was she a
virgin when you met her no no okay so
you know that point just exemplifies
what I'm talking about like you weren't
her first you weren't her first and only
she had been with other guys right so
the first guy that she was was with
might have thought oh she's mine because
I've committed to her and she's my
girlfriend and probably had the same you
know level of thinking if I take her out
and treat her well and you know think
that it's forever that it'll last
forever but that but that theory was
violated and now she's with you right so
to suggest that it's that it's a whinge
or a wine is a little bit uh
disingenuous because it's just a
statement of fact I mean let's say you
make it work let's say that you guys are
together you know until death do you
part sort of thing awesome good for you
but on the balance of probabilities for
for most people today
um they're not just going to marry their
first and be with a person in fact you
weren't with her right well yeah and to
me that's the way I'm saying to me it's
not about the the sexual thing or
anything oh well did you sleep with her
before you know and all that or whatever
it may be it's not about that's that's
not what keeps a woman like sleeping
with her obviously is not one of the
things that's going to keep your woman
you have to make sure you are the man
that you need to be for her and that she
is and she is the woman that you want to
marry but how many guys have you ever
call into my show and had been the like
I'll give you a really good example so
Monday night on the unplugged Alpha I
got a guy lined up who lives in British
Columbia and his uh Ukrainian wife which
I think he met uh in Eastern Europe has
now taken his kids stolen them from him
and he legitimately had the same
position that you did you know until
death he was part I can mature I do the
right thing I provide I'm a good husband
and she went off you know porking some
other guy and left him and took the kids
and now he's fighting to see his own
children he's out of money and he's over
his head in debt right like
it's not a particularly realistic
position to you know just to say that if
I'm good to her and I take care of her
and I'm a nice guy and I uh you know
remove uncomfortable truths of my belief
system that things are just going to
work out because what ends up happening
is a lot of these guys that believe that
um end up putting things like nooses
around their necks or you can even you
know find the video somewhere on my
channel where I had a Mexican uh of a
veterinarian who is ready to jam a horse
tranquilizer dart in his leg and end his
life because of what happened with his
life because she violated that safe oral
theory that you know if you just commit
and you're with her and you're a good
guy that everything will be fine I want
guys to wake up to the reality of life
and just understand that you know things
aren't what you think they are right
like that's what the whole process of
unplugging is right so the reason why
you have some difficulty with it is
because it's uncomfortable for you
because you don't want to think that she
can bounce on you no no I think that's
very simplified what I'm saying it's not
about being a nice guy you still have to
and this is what I mean to me you have
to leave your home you know whether you
want to call Alpha or whatever yeah I'm
on the same page with you yeah you have
to lead your home you have to lead your
wife to lead your woman right it's not
just it's like no you're not going out
and doing stuff like that it's not like
oh well I'm just going to be a nice guy
and hopefully she doesn't no it's
nothing like that it's way more to it
than that I think it's an opacification
and it's not pushing away An
Inconvenient Truth I'm all about
inconvenient truths and convenient
truths I think you're calling an income
convenient truth whining
well no to me the whining part is if
you're going to say well I'm just going
to be a nice guy and she's just going to
you know stay with me and oh well
actually no even though I'm a nice guy
it's not my turn it's just my turn and I
just have to wait around and see what
happens no it's not about being a nice
guy it's about being a leader and saying
no you're not you're done you're done
running around
that's how that's so [ __ ] paraphrase
just so I understand so what you're
saying is if you remove that belief and
you do all the right things in your
marriage
um then everything should be fine and
that's not what I'm saying okay so what
I'm saying is yeah I'll clarify what I'm
saying is that you tell your woman right
you say hey look if she's if she's one
of those women that are running around
you think she's cute and you want to
marry her whatever maybe you want to be
with her you say hey look you're done
with the sleeping around and the other
guys right for my wife I didn't have to
do that she was young when she uh when
we when we first met we were both young
when we first met right so we wouldn't
we didn't have that experience a whole
bunch of guys sleeping around and all
that stuff and all this craziness it was
we just met and we dated she had a past
and that was it right so I didn't have
to kind of lay down the law necessarily
and be like you're done but if I had to
I would and there are things in our
marriage we've been married for almost
10 years where I've had to say we're
done with this we're not doing this here
we're not doing this thing we're not
doing that thing so you lead your just
like you would lead your children you
lead your family I know some people may
think this is a problem but I do see as
a tear system I think that it's men
women children right and so you have as
a man you have to lead your spouse and
if she is the one going around doing
certain things and even if some somehow
she goes off the rails and she goes off
with that you got to say hey look we're
done with this right you got to leave
that so that's to me in my mindset it's
not saying oh Inconvenient Truth like if
if she's the type of woman that's
sleeping around first of all that's
probably another woman you want to be
with now if she is the woman that you're
that's sleeping around and you really
want to be with her you really want to
you know work things out I don't suggest
you do it like I said like I told with
Mom spend time with women that are not
sleeping around like that there are
women out there that are like that it's
not the world all right so let's go
check something during an opportunity
because because here's what it sounded
like to me I think we agree far more
that we disagree I think that what I'm
hearing this is the equivalent of what
we call like a natural Alpha who shits
on like Pua and game like you understand
this stuff at a fundamental level that
it's imp it's it's pertinent that you be
the leader and you take charge and be
the man in your household and do the
things necessary to keep your wife
attracted to you keep your by your side
all that kind of stuff we're everybody
on this panel is fully behind that we
talk about that stuff all the time now
the rub becomes
there's so many guys the vast majority
of guys out there think that put the
ring on the finger the baby in the belly
the house over the head the dog in the
yard she's yours forever and now you get
to spend your Sundays in your lazy boy
watching football eating chips drinking
beer right so
that's like I think we agree more than
we that's that's what's happening here
you're basically coming on and saying
hey when we're saying like hey most guys
need game because most guys can't get
laid and you're like no bro just be
confident right that's kind of what's
Happening like you get it at a
fundamental level so it's totally fine
for you to reject this premise like well
it's not my turn with my wife she's my
wife forever because do you know why
because you're doing the work and you're
doing the things that are going to keep
her or ensure that you keep her the best
of your ability we don't know we can't
predict the future we have no idea
what's going to happen all we can do is
give ourselves the best shot that we can
possibly give ourselves so we're far
more on the same page than we're not
I I but I think that's where we are I
think I think we agree more than we
disagree sure
yeah from the get-go I was just going to
ask what your dating experience was like
but in the banter between you and Rich
uh that that came out of you but you did
mention that you're married a bit
younger
um one congratulations for having like a
happy healthy marriage I know if we're
being honest a lot of guys in this space
that's what they really want actually
yeah
um I was in that camp too grew up in
real conservative and then like Rich
laid out the scenario what usually
happens I let my game slip a bit and she
was gone so
um I think probably more than follow-up
questions right I just have a a word of
advice for younger guys if you get
married really really young
um and neither of you have that dating
experience that's great I think that
does lead to higher likelihood of the
marriage uh lasting but you also have to
realize that as you go through different
life stages that and especially the info
the outside influencers upon her you
have to really make sure you don't let
your game slip and you have to be be on
top of who she's hanging out with who
she's talking to what's her co-workers
like what is her work environment like
because you could be the Rock Solid man
in the house all you want but if she's
coming home at 6 7 8 P.M you're cooking
dinner real quick you're watching a
couple hours of TV going to bed and then
she's up taking the kids to school
tonight again and you really don't have
that one-to-one face time to nurture
that relationship and re-establish that
fact that I am indeed the man and then
she goes and works for a man for eight
nine ten hours a day then those outside
influences could be potentially uh
harmful to your relationship so I'd say
that's probably just a word of advice
yeah and all right
um so let's go to the next point so what
was the other one that you had no yeah
okay so then just the idea what was it
the women don't wait at women don't uh
choose men sorry for important
disappointing but they wait at the
finish line and they picked the winner
or something like it doesn't yeah women
don't care about your struggles they
waited
all it is is that just uh summarizes
what Evo psych discovered is that men
compete women choose
so the issue with that was
no to me I just I don't I guess I don't
see it that way and even if that let's
say that is you know the way that you
were competing for your wife
in a sense yes but what I wanted yeah
what I want to say too is that like I
said going back to that mindset of just
it's not that you're ignoring the
Inconvenient Truth it's like okay sure
that whatever yeah I but I I kind of
like what
um Scott was saying like you need to
step your game up don't let your game
slip I guess it's like this is the type
of man you need to be regardless it's
like you don't need to because if you're
just trying to be the winner and you're
doing the right things and you're just
but you're still not leading like you're
maybe yeah maybe a woman is gonna slip
out on you you know but I don't know
what that would look like because I
don't understand what like what the
disagreement is with men compete women
shoes or that women wait at the finish
line and pick the winner they don't care
about your struggles because there's
this like age-old notion from the mantle
swamp where you hear a lot of these uh
dudes are all like you know hypergamy
doesn't care about uh
you know you losing your job you
whatever like whatever difficulties come
your way women don't have a lot of
patience and tolerance for guys so
um one of the plugged in narratives that
a lot of guys subscribe to which I don't
think serves guys is when they start to
uh take the Hook Line and Sinker of uh
in sickness and health and richness and
poorness and but like you know it's
implying that it doesn't matter what
your condition is a woman will always be
there for you but the fact of life is is
that women divorce men something like
eight or nine times out of ten they
leave marriages eight or nine times out
of ten and as a guy that spent a lot of
time dating divorce women after I got
divorced myself all I heard when I asked
some questions about why they're no
longer with their husband he was a loser
he was a beta he was dumb he was
incompetent he couldn't keep a job down
he wasn't a good provider he was
depressed and locked himself in his room
and all these women left these guys for
those reasons and then I started looking
at Evo psych studies and like holy [ __ ]
it's actually a statement of fact that
men compete and women choose from the
men that compete so when I say they
don't care about your struggles they
hang out at the finish line and pick the
winner
I don't see the problem with that and
I'm waiting to hear what right you have
a problem with that not five years of
our marriage probably even the beginning
of our marriage
um I was really sick I had fibromyalgia
hypoglycemia I was really really sick
now I'm a lot healthier now
um reversed everything by the grace of
God believe it was a miracle of God and
I'm back to being personal trainer
everything is you know
uh physically everything is great and so
but my wife was there when I was sick I
mean I had Rhabdomyolysis and she you
know had a bun in the oven while wait
while I'm in the hospital right okay so
she was pregnant too yeah so look man
not not every chick is going to abandon
the guy that she's married to when she's
pregnant some will some won't yours
happened to stick around and you know
nurse or help you back to health or
nurse you back to health or do the right
thing not all women will do that though
and given the opportunity if she may not
have been pregnant or a better guy may
have come along she may have bounced on
you so no so because even when I you
know I don't think that that she might
have done something like that I was sick
even before she was pregnant so here's
the thing here's what I'm trying to say
right this puts in a mindset for these
young men out there that would think oh
man I can't get sick I can't if I get
laid out what I'm saying dude it's like
nothing can happen to me because if I do
no no no no no no no that's not what I'm
saying at all it's it's just a statement
of human nature that men need to compete
and women choose from the men that that
actually compete and that marriage is no
buffer to keep that Union together
um like look if if a woman has an
opportunity to improve her circumstances
and you're not getting better or
improving your circumstances within a
determined period of time
on a balance of probabilities she's
probably going to leave that marriage we
know that for a fact based on marriage
stats
I just don't see as a young like as a
young okay so for you okay so for you it
it didn't go that way right right fine
cool awesome I'm I'm very happy for you
thank you but I've got another question
for you private prior to your marriage
and this one the first ones I was gonna
ask what was your experience like with
women prior to marriage like did you
have a pretty high Notch count and I
know guys in the space like oh it
doesn't matter well it does matter like
if I'm going to take advice on how to be
a home run hitter I'm going to ask Aaron
judge over the the guy that lives next
door and has never lace up a pair of
cleats and stepped on the field so what
what's your experience like like do you
have enough volume to safely make these
assumptions or to come and say that oh I
don't agree with this because you've
you've put in the you've you've put in
the work and gotten the Reps uh at a
woman I guess
so my mind so this is like the mindset
that I think is wrong it's like oh that
is the main and be all and end-all like
putting in the Reps getting a body count
and all this stuff I mean like I said I
married young so I wasn't you know
sleeping around with women did I talk to
women yeah was I able to like talk to
somebody if I wanted to stuff like that
you know to me it wasn't about body
counts or Notch counts or anything like
that and I think that's where the issue
is I think it's just a different pool of
human beings that we're hanging out with
right like if like rich brought up the
the divorcement that he talked to he was
saying like oh what kind of guys you
were doing oh they were losers they were
this they were that first of all
um but married to like we're married
right right I wouldn't be around women
that would talk about a man like that
one second I wouldn't well the woman you
marry is not the woman that you divorce
I understand hold on in second if I was
a if I was a woman I wouldn't be around
a man that has the propensity to lock
himself in a room and just you know
again but you're but you're not a woman
and the woman that you marry is not that
you're divorced like circumstances
change over time and marriages right
granted my point is though the people
that are
being spent time with women and men to
me I feel like it's just a different
pool it's a different pool of people
that you have to spend time with if
you're going to spend time with women
that talk about men like that I I
wouldn't even be in the same room with a
woman that talks about you think even if
you think that any of those divorce
women spoke about their husbands on the
engagement night during the wedding
ceremony when they gave the speech at
the wedding in front of 300 people do
you think any of them spoke that way
about their husbands of course not no
but because they failed in their eyes
they have to disparage them to justify
why they left the Union
fair enough but what I'm what I'm trying
to say is that let's say you were
talking to that woman right and she said
you were dating her right and she said
oh he was a loser he was this he was
that in my mind I'd like hmm this is
probably not a woman I should be hanging
out with talking about a man in that way
you know and maybe exactly it's a red
flag it's in my red flag chapter and
that's why I discontinued any
association I'm good because and I
thought maybe it was a paraphrase maybe
she used
words exactly that's not a woman you
want to spend time with absolutely
because she would be discreet maybe
saying okay you know something happened
and this and that that will be more of
like okay yeah okay maybe you can you
both can translate in your mind never
say it out loud yeah he's a loser he
locked himself in the room all this blah
blah but if she's talking like that
which I don't want to blame the point
because you kind of agree with me but
the point is
for me it's just a different type of
pool like I wouldn't want to go up to a
you understand there's some nuances
though here with a lot of the stuff that
I talk about like like there's no
completely black and white you know
answer to everything what I'm what I'm
providing men with is tools to
understand the reality of human nature
when they engage into life when it comes
to making money when it comes to dealing
with women and stuff like that like you
said you're a personal trainer right
yeah like you probably have to go
through some conversations about well
some of that stuff that's in your pantry
is not going to align with your goals so
if you want to get these goals you're
going to have to stop putting this [ __ ]
in your face right so but
I can guarantee you when I was 20 years
old I could have eaten whatever I wanted
and been jacked as [ __ ] right so there's
there's nuances but the reality is is if
you want to get the body that you want
if you want to look the way that you
want like you know the magazine models
and stuff like that you're going to have
to lift the weights you're going to have
to eat you know a good diet you're going
to have to sleep
um do you have to sleep nine hours or do
you have to sleep eight point five hours
or do you have to sleep 6.5 hours the
fact of the matter is you're going to
have to get sufficient sleep so when I'm
saying things like
you know men compete women shoes or that
women don't care about your struggles
they hang out at the finish line and
they pick the winner on a balance of
probabilities it's right almost all of
the time hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out